hello and welcome to another uh
stock indicators mathematics tutorial
video in this video we're going to be
talking about how we actually finally
graph our shaken volatility
indicator so if you didn't already do it
you'll have to get the sample code from
my website
and this would be the sample code link
will be in the description
go ahead and just highlight all of that
copy that
paste that
so now that's going to plot up a chart
with an empty bottom indicator now the
next thing that we want to do is
actually take our old calculation here
everything we just did we don't need
this top stuff we don't need an ema
because we already do that but we are
going to need percent change and shaken
volatility all the way down to the
actual calling of that so copy that come
over here and just paste that in let me
bring this over now
and then when you're done highlight it
all
and uh then hit tab tab and get it to go
to where we want it
finally
we want to say since this returns two uh
variable
you know data sets basically we can say
cbd for shaking volatility date cv for
shaking volatility equals that and now
let's actually plot those so it's going
to be ax two dot
plot and we want to plot cbd
minus sp colon um that's just like our
starting point if you want to know more
about why we're doing that it's just so
the data lines up and if you want to
know even more about that watch my
charting stocks in python and matplotlib
uh tutorial series minus sp cone
and then we want to make this line a
white line
then we're also going to do plot.y label
and that will be a shaken ball
uh
10 10
and then the color for this will be
white
and that's really it so let's go ahead
and run that so press f5
get that to run
and let's look at att
so here is our shaken volatility for
a t shaken ball 1010
let's fit it to screen here
got the wrong arrow
so here we have shaken volatility uh you
know as it's crashing it's going up and
it continues going up
um
then again here you know volatility is
going up volatility volatility's going
up
so anyway that would be our shake and
volatility let's look at another one
real quick and we can probably stop
printing out shape and volatility
so go ahead and rerun that again
uh let's look at
apple
so here is our apple graph again the
volatility really rockets up here if you
look you might not be able to see it in
my video but if you're looking at it
yourself you can see where kind of the
price did kind of crash a little bit
there
then as it flat lines here you can see
how volatility really came down to the
zero mark
and so on so anyway um that's going to
conclude the shaken volatility
calculation tutorial video hopefully you
guys enjoyed hopefully learn something
new as always thanks for watching thanks
for all the support the subscriptions
and until next time